I am in love with this dog
in love Oh Oh Ron yes what's up everyone
welcome to this Google hangout over here
my name is Jason Silva and in case you
guys are not aware I create in
partnership with my pals at revision3 we
create shots of awe shots of awe is a
weekly series of short nuggets of techno
rapture that celebrate big ideas that
celebrate inspiration that celebrate
those moments that would make final cut
I am an inspiration junkie I love to be
elated and I'm here to take your
questions and chat with you about
youtube.com slash shots of awe I am also
the host of brain games on National
Geographic Channel and I'm excited that
you guys are here and I'm open to all of
it I'm hearing I'm hearing a playback
right now of what I just recorded yes
it's already playing back okay there we
go
all right everyone sorry technical
failure we actually had a power failure
at the office where we're gonna do this
human technology coevolution collapse
ironically you know Here I am talking
about singularity and we lost power but
anyway ask away I'm here for you let's
chat let's create a techno social
wormhole of communication in transcend
time space and distance all right okay
Oh can you speak on the possibility of a
dystopian singularity what are the
potential threats of a utopian future
sure look I think Kurzweil has has
talked about this a lot as well you know
technology has always been a
double-edged sword you know technology
extends our reach but it can extend our
reach in any direction you know perhaps
the man that discovered fire as Kurzweil
says could have was probably burned at
the stake by his contemporaries so we
can use fire to cook our foods and you
can use fire to burn one another so we
use these tools we use these instruments
to extend the boundaries of our thought
of our reach of our vision you know to
extend ourselves but it's how we choose
to extend ourselves that ultimately
determines the effect that technology
has on our future and I think that's
where cultural narratives are important
that's where memes are important that's
where you know again these narratives
that will ultimately inform how we use
these tools are crucial so you know
that's why publishing platforms like Ted
are so important that's why I make my
videos to put them out there to kind of
inspire a greater vision of life a
greater vision of what's possible but if
you actually map out human progress over
the last hundred years contrary to
popular belief we have used these tools
to make life better
I mean Steven Pinker's work talks about
the fact that the chances of a man dying
at the hands of another man today are
the lowest than they've ever been the
world has actually never been less
violent than it is today
contrary to popular belief so you know
it's not utopia yet but it's leaning
that way and Steven Johnson likes to say
more questions let's see what are the
act can take beyond reading and talking
about this kind of Awesome vision
well I think use the tools at your
disposal to basically put out your
unique vision out into the world like
we've never had such tools with which to
create ripples that can transform right
I mean it's this idea that you know a
young person with a cell phone in Africa
today has better communications
technology than the US President had 25
years ago so how might this young child
used this tool how might he use it to
extend his creativity to remix his
sphere of possibilities I mean it's not
my job I think to tell you how or what
you can do it's mostly just to inspire
you to believe that you can but I think
you have to ultimately discover your own
path what is your contribution gonna be
that I think is the question we can all
ask ourselves in fact at singularity
University in Silicon Valley they've
created this this this whole this whole
University at the NASA Ames campus to
encourage and teach people to think
exponentially about what's possible the
idea is that you know passionate
individuals today can do what only
governments and corporations used to do
mere decades ago you know the tools to
change the world are in everybody's
hands you know it's it's I think that's
a wonderful idea because on the back of
these Exponential's you are now more
empowered than you've ever been so again
the question is what is your
contribution going to be
um let's see
can
a controlled singularity yeah you know I
think the matrix was presented as a
dystopian meditation on control and
freewill and identity because dystopian
stories and conflicts make more
entertaining movies you know but that
stuff that was sort of hypothesized in
that film sounds pretty glorious I mean
wouldn't you like to inhabit a kind of
virtual world and distinguishable from
this one but one in which the laws of
the very physics the very constructs of
said reality are completely malleable
why can't we all be nito's in the matrix
you know why can't we all move into
universes of our own construction I mean
Terence Mckenna says the man-made world
is already a condensation of the
imagination the whole thing has been
sprouted from the human mind so in the
film The Matrix they're just again I
didn't see it as a bad thing you know
for us to live in this virtual utopia
but the film found it necessary to say
oh humans didn't accept the program and
it was perfect they only accepted it
when there was conflict and then on and
on and then it went off in that other
direction but yeah that's kind of a
singularity the minute you crew create
an AI they can build a world for you
that's a singularity why not um have you
read radical evolution by Joel Cairo
heard of it read pieces of it haven't
read the whole thing
Huell is it to be in the Joe Rogan
podcast I love Joe Rogan I think that he
is you know he's got something really
amazing with that podcast it's it's it's
you know it's a it's a labor of love he
produces it with his friends they blast
it out into the world unedited and they
touch on such a range of topics you know
from MMA to consciousness expansion to
the technological singularity he's that
everybody from like sam Harris to you
know comedians to me you know it's it's
it's it's an absolute honor to have been
there three times and the response that
I got from appearing on the Joe Rogan
podcast has has been superb I mean they
live the sort of passionate nature of
his fans and his followers has is
humbling but it's kind of wonderful the
same time
have you thought about writing a book
anytime soon you know I've actually been
contacted by several publishers and book
agents believe it or not ever since this
the you know my videos going viral and
doing all the keynotes around the world
and also brain games that I host the
National Geographic has been a
highest-rated series launch in the
history of NatGeo as well so all these
things can happen at once I've kind of
experiencing my own like singularity in
a way you know with shots of awe and you
know brain games and speaking and so
people have started to approach me about
writing a book and I've hesitated a
little bit because a part of me feels
like you know I believe in in remix and
mashup culture and I'm not really an
academic so my book would be essay istic
you know it would be kind of stream of
consciousness of the references and the
anchor point to the frameworks of
reality that I'm currently surfing but
you know if people are expecting an
academic book that's not what they're
gonna get from me I'll have this fantasy
of doing a coffee table book with images
from the imaginary foundation mixed with
like my favorite essay so it's more like
a curatorial effort but I would grab
selections from Terence Mckenna and
Timothy Leary and Eric Davis and then
images from the imaginary foundation and
then maybe some pictures of like you
know just beautiful
images that I stumble upon that would be
kind of Awesome what is transcend time
and space you say this will be fun well
yeah well look that's kind of what these
technologies allow us to do something
I've been thinking about lately is a how
we use you know airplanes have forced us
to to Rhea comma date ourselves to
renegotiate our relationship to dot to
distance and to time and to scale you
know what is close and what is far when
it takes you you know three hours and
traffic to get from Uptown you know to
downtown but then three hours can also
take you to another side of the
continent I mean these machines they
transforms all notions of scale all
notions of distance but psychologically
it's still a real combination right I
feel very disjoint that when I take
these long trips because there's
something kind of a kind of just
supernatural almost about these magical
machines you know that fly through the
sky and we somehow take it for granted
and you know ambert case the cyborg
anthropologist says that even right now
here in a techno social wormhole
we've you know created this hole in
space and time and wherever you guys are
you can hear me you can talk to me I can
hear you I mean the human mind at least
the part of the mind that is
communicating communication itself
between sentient Minds has transcended
time space and distance I think that's
kind of unbelievable
virtual reality is coming any worlds and
particularly you like to visit oh my god
yeah I want to visit like Jodie Foster's
wormhole in the movie contact when she's
like literally riding a roller coaster
through the universe that would be rad
also the kind of utopian romantic
projection of like Cameron Crowe's
Vanilla Sky
you know the lucid dream where the
character of David Ames it creates this
you know virtual lucid dream that
sculpted out of the iconography of his
youth so images of pop-culture
references of love of what love is like
of what friendship is like all these
things are in form his lucid dream so
like a virtual space that's rendered at
the speed of your thoughts or rather
your fantasies sounds pretty rad
to create and perceive your world at the
same time like the dream sequences and
Inception how awesome would that be what
is your take on aliens well I think that
it is inevitable that intelligent life
either will be or has evolved somewhere
else in the universe it seems to me my
intuition tells me it's too big it's too
vast the scales are too difficult to
fathom for there not to be something
else like what occurred here whether
they've visited us or not not convinced
most UFO footage looks like a hoax
whether panspermia was responsible for
putting life on Earth you know whether
the building blocks of life were sent
here I mean that idea of panspermia is
kind of amazing especially because
Freeman Dyson the physicist says that we
need to do that soon we need to take all
the DNA of life on earth and send it out
into space you know so who knows maybe
this I'm intelligent you know
super alien intelligence did that to
seed the life on this planet it's
interesting to speculate about I I mean
I just I love the the mystery of that
the possibility of that you know there's
an interesting thing called the
transection hypothesis that I made a
video about that is it tries to explain
Fermi's paradox which is if the universe
is so vast why don't we see any evidence
of these extraterrestrial civilizations
and the reason is that as complexity and
technology evolves we stop expanding
outwards and we start expanding inwards
the whole thing about stem compression
the compression of space time energy and
matter means we start to put more
computation more complexity and some
denser and denser spaces until you have
computation at the level of the nano
scale and the femto scale and literally
you're concentrating the into a point
where you literally create black hole
like conditions and virtual realities
and digital Minds disappear into those
black hole light conditions and
slingshot to the end of the universe the
end of space-time and that's where all
the other extraterrestrial civilizations
are and so that's why we don't see them
anywhere because they exist outside of
the observable universe because of this
like inevitable stem compression that
happens when technology reaches that
singularity so that's why I think we
can't see the aliens maybe because of
immortality our brains help us make
decisions to keep us alive because we
are afraid to die what do you think our
world would be like without these
limitations I mean I think about Robert
ed Inger wrote man into Superman and he
says together we shall taste the wine of
centuries unborn I mean nobody's gonna
convince me with that a death hist
rationalization that says that oh death
gives meaning to life and we would be
bored if we were immortal I'm sorry man
I think that that's just because we're
poetic and we found a way to accommodate
ourselves to personal extinction but I
birds of Alan Harrington that says any
philosophy that accepts death must
itself be considered that it's questions
meaningless consolations worn out I'm
sorry I'm just
nobody's gonna convince me to accept the
inevitability of a loss the
inevitability of losing everyone I care
about I just do not accept I just I defy
those conditions I do not accept those
terms I love too much you know I love my
family I love the people in my life and
I just don't accept that this imposition
dislike entropy things as oh love each
other for as long as you can because
you're all gonna be food for worms you
know not cool I think that the purpose
of human evolution is to transcend
entropy is to basically engineer our own
divinity that's that's what it means to
be human to to transcend all previous
limits
I think we can talk about anything
because they are of metaphor you can
talk about unknowable things using
metaphors I mean even singularity is a
physics term you know it has it's a
physics term borrowed to describe this
event horizon the moment at which you
know AI becomes smarter than the human
brain and so thinking itself takes a
mention that is unfathomable to human
brains without augmentation I mean the
whole idea of it is use language we use
poetry to describe the ineffable you
know that's that's that's another great
skill set that we happen to have so I do
think we could speculate about what the
singularity how it might play out but
sure yeah to imagine what it will be
like is as difficult as trying to
imagine what the world post language
would have been to early hominids on the
other side of that line if you try to
explain to a chimp the nuances of a
Shakespearean sonnet you know I mean
it's not that easy they don't have the
mental software to be able to run that
in their heads yeah which is a shame
because they're missing out
Hawking says that if we don't back up
humanity with yeah look we have backups
for our iPhones we need to back up our
mind file we need to back up our DNA we
need to back up humanity I do think that
we need that that we need to back up
yeah we need to back ourselves up why
wouldn't we what a tragic thing it would
be to you know to not be backed up and
be hit by a train Oh can't imagine
anything more horrible what else we got
what else we got
your response can weave and talk more
telling consumers the Internet already
being an AI well there's a great
metaphor of course it says it as we all
join the internet you know in terms of
like scale and emergence just like 10
trillion cells decided to team up and
become this super organism called the
human being now you know billions of
human beings are like teaming up and
becoming this super organism called the
internet and the Internet is wiring all
of us together like individual synapses
and this these synapses are becoming
like this global brain and then
eventually when there's sufficient
interconnection is sufficient complexity
a new kind of planetary consciousness
might emerge from that and there's one
of those things where you can't plan
that's all thing about emergence if
Alexa T leads to something different but
some of the parts adds up to more than
the parts that is what emergence is so
even if that did happen I don't know if
we would be aware of it the very same
way that the cells that make up the
individual cells in my body's probably
are not like aware that that their
aggregate is this like super organism
right so yeah the internet could lead to
that but I don't know if we would be
aware wow man will not merely do what he
will prevail how far oh wow
William Faulkner said man will not just
endure he will prevail I love that
that's a beautiful thing you know that's
like that's like the guy that said first
we build the tools then they build us he
also said that he's confident that men
will learn the songs that orchestrate
the universe I mean look at us we're
pretty exceptional species I mean our
ability to just like reverse-engineer
reality to make it I mean it's just I
don't know III look at what we've done
so far and it makes me think there's
nothing we can't do I think it was
Sophocles who says manifold the wonders
nothing towers more wondrous than man I
agree I think it's sad that a lot of
people fail to see that but I think it's
my mission in life to get them to see it
besides what is life if not the pursuit
of a dream the dream of transcendence
the dream of glory the dream of surfing
all previous limits
row row row your boat gently down the
stream merrily merrily merrily merrily
life is but a dream what else might
house Plato's allegory of the cave ooh
that's a good one
I love the amount of enthusiam have what
inspired you to be an influential type
of speaker interesting thank you for
that I didn't plan to have a speaking
career I worked at current Al Gore's TV
network for four years and I was hosting
a show on Current and when I left I
wanted to go back to create the kind of
content that moved me profoundly which
was content that reflected my
philosophical sensibilities and my love
of just like aesthetic aesthetically
relevant presentation and I started
doing these short videos the
philosophical espresso shots as a way of
creating a visual art form a format so
to speak the short form communication
style that was built around how I talked
I just so happened to go on these rants
for two minutes I mean you hang out with
me you'll see is I thought maybe I can
take some of my most lucid rants on my
favorite ideas and edit them with music
and imagery and put people in my head to
turn my subjectivity into a visual
externalized art you could see so it's
like you could see my could see the
butterfly effect in thought as I was
going through it and the videos took off
and would happen as people would see the
work people see the videos it was a way
of like discovering these ideas which is
ultimately what these were about
trailers for ideas and then I you know I
got to speak of the singularity summit
and I had really good feedback from that
and then I spoke at another economist
ideas conference that really good
feedback from that and if I had can I
have a knack for it because I'm so
passionate about these ideas that it
flowed very naturally then tEDGlobal
came to me and of course the illustrious
TED Conference so amazing they had me do
a video for them called radical openness
which I premiered on the Ted stage and
from that things just snowballed I've
since spoken at the festival of
Dangerous Ideas in the Sydney Opera
House which was amazing I've done
corporate keynotes for IBM and Intel and
Microsoft and Adobe and Oracle I mean
it's it's taken off and just I'm just
really grateful because um you know it's
like Joseph Campbell used to say follow
your bliss and doors will open where
there were no doors and that's kind of
how it feels you know it's it's it's uh
it's really wild you know it's like that
scene in the matrix when neo like has
that realization he can see the code and
he can rewrite
code and a lot of these limitations in
these frameworks of reality are just
that they're just their software that
can be hacked you know I love the term
reality hacking you know the only thing
standing in your way is you
you know big idea the idea of overcoming
entropy humans can influence chaos and
organize it with nothing but our minds
what do you think I completely buy into
that notion I think entropy is an
existential bummer I think that life is
anti-entropic as Bucky fuller used to
say we move towards greater complexity
we don't accept these existential
bummers if we don't have to and you know
we've already doubled the human lifespan
and that was before the revolutions and
domestication of biotechnology I was
just watching that video of that little
girl that was cured from cancer by them
putting HIV in her they reprogrammed the
HIV virus so that it would attack her
cancer cells talk about hacking the
software of life like literally they
made the virus attack her cancer cells
and she got cured there's nothing we
can't do man we are as gods love it
what's on your head are you ever in
Venice actually it says deus ex machina
if the s in the Deus was an X it would
be God in the machine so I discovered
this company I was in Australia and I
had another one this is deus ex machina
the god isn't the machine i thought it
would be funny because i talked about
the singularity and that's like
engineering divinity so that's where
that comes from
um would you consider cloning yourself
when possible hahaha wow thanks
I haven't thought about that yet I I
mean I think that uh
that would be interesting I haven't
thought about it but yeah you were going
to college nowadays to study science
technology which field would you pursue
because of the current potential
I think anything any of these emerging
technologies anything that's emerging
exponentially I would encourage people
to go singularity University actually
where they focus on Exponential's
exponential thinking I think is key
because we have these been these brains
that just intuitively thing colinear lis
but progress is exponential so we need
to reprogram our brains to think
exponentially Venus Project yes I'm
aware of it
love the artwork for it it looks amazing
it looks beautiful with Jacque fresco
definitely a smart guy I think it's cool
I think all all possible utopian visions
are worth investigating and pursuing in
some capacity just the idea of us trying
to create perfection turns me on you
know
future is already here it's just
unevenly distributed
yeah people talk about this all the time
they say yes these technologies sound
great but what about the info nots
you know we have the info haves and you
have the info nots Kurzweil answered
this brilliantly he says people are
afraid these technologies are only for
the rich and he answers yeah like cell
phones right I mean when cell phones
were first created they were expensive
clunky didn't work very well and perhaps
only if you could two could afford
them today a young person with a cell
phone in Africa has better
communications technology than the US
President had 25 years ago so these
technologies they improve exponentially
they get cheaper they get more
accessible and they get more affordable
so I don't think these technologies are
just for the rich at all I think they
spread and they become available to
everyone what does you take
rationale see frequency multiverses
ascension well I can't speak too much
about any of those other than the
multiverse idea they sort of the
parallel universe theory of quantum
mechanics that was proposed by Hugh
Everett the third is this idea that the
only way to explain quantum physics is
to assume that every possible thing that
could ever possibly happen is happening
in some kind of parallel universe to
ours there was a great book called the
man who turned into himself which took
that idea and wrote like a fictional
account of it this guy like his wife
dies and he just can't bear the pain and
somehow he learns to surf between
parallel universes and he ends up going
to the other parallel universe in which
his wife didn't die and then gets to be
with her you know it's kind of an
amazing story also Michael Crichton's
book timeline used a parallel universe
theory of quantum mechanics to achieve
time-travel because obviously I can't go
to the past of this universe but I can
go to a parallel universe in which there
present looks a lot like what our past
looked like and in order to get to that
parallel universe you can't fit a human
through a wormhole but you can send a
fax the same way you can't put a piece
of paper through a telephone line but
you can send a fax so they figure out
how to scan the information equivalent
of the human being
destroy the human on this side at the
same time as they zap you through the
wormhole and then the other universe
reconstructs you upon receiving your
particles somehow you sort of self
organize and you just pop out the other
side it's kind of an idea but a kind of
while idea but Michael Crichton and
timeline explored in a pretty cool way
can't believe I actually remember that
but how are we doing
who are some of your idols
I adore Kevin Kelly's writings he's
brilliant
what technology wants is genius I like
turns McKenna's ideas of a new vert
universe that engenders novelty I like
Timothy Leary who says that our
technology is the literalization of the
psychedelic dream of mind expansion I
really like film directors Cameron Crowe
with the Vanilla Sky as an idol danny
boyle who did Slumdog Millionaire 127
hours trance the beach she's a total
Idol Ron Howard who I've recently become
friends with total Idol
Apollo 13 beautiful mine and his new
film rush I love these guys Christopher
Nolan who did inception I do think that
they'll make ecstatic shamans they take
us to places of ecstatic illumination
their masters in the art of capturing
and managing attention they can orient
our awareness to psychological spaces
too subjective spaces of grand visions
and grand possibilities I love those
guys what do you think of David Pierce's
idea of utopia I love David Pierce I
love him he's a hedonistic imperative I
think is brilliant everybody should
check that out it's this online treatise
on how we should use biotechnology and
nanotechnology to engineer suffering out
of existence like physical suffering
pain malaise death disease like
literally eliminated and just literally
like transform ourselves you know like
caterpillars turning themselves into
butterflies I mean it plays out in
nature why can't we do it we are nature
too that's the thing you shouldn't
forget we are nature everything we do is
nature okay
you guys are enjoying this conversation
I would ask you to go to youtube.com
slash shots of awe and subscribe to my
channel because we're popping out new
videos every week every week I'm putting
in new shots of awe video like I'm
working with my friends here like
they're they're awesome I mean the
images the music that's micro
psychedelic experience it's like
downloading the universe so please
please subscribe youtube.com slash shots
of awe also follow me on twitter i'm at
jason silva Silv a act Jason Silva I
have a verified account I'm easy to find
follow me on Twitter and stay connected
so we can keep this kind of two-way
conversation going keep the techni
social wormhole open keep it stable
prediction of Moore's law the
exponential growth will decelerate I
don't think so I think that every time
the people are afraid that Moore's law
that the Exponential's are going to
stabilize there is a new sort of
paradigm shift some new crazy logic
comes online and Moore's law just
continues right like even gene
sequencing is going three times faster
than Moore's law at the moment so I
don't think it's going to stop on the
last Joe Rogan
touched on comedy being kind of
philosophy could you elaborate yes well
comedians are the original stand-up
philosophers or at least the
contemporary standard philosophers I
think there's not a lot of spaces today
outside of university campuses where
somebody can stand up and pontificate on
things I mean I try to do it
I try to do it in my talks you know but
um you know comics like Joe Rogan like
George Carlin like Bill Maher these are
contemporary philosophers I mean they
get up on stage and they think out loud
and they ruin it with you and they share
anecdotes and make observations about
the world they philosophize and then
they have this humorous twist we laugh
because we relate to what they're saying
because they mirror us brilliantly so I
definitely think that comedians are our
contemporary stand-up philosophers
technology
of ourselves or a reflection of
ourselves our true potential look I
think technology again is our second
skin it's like the termite colony is
temperature controlled you know but it's
still part of the termite species right
like the spider's web you know it's
still part of the spider like we need to
think of our cities our skyscrapers and
our jet engines as literally things that
are spilling over out of the organism
like these are if we were able to
time-lapse progress it would look like
our our grand visions and our grand
dreams spill over from our brains this
is the world that we live in this is
what we are and anyway cool guys this
has been fun I tire easily because I'm
very passionate as you can tell but I've
had a great time chatting with you and I
hope that you guys will subscribe to
youtube.com slash shots of awe follow me
on Twitter on at Jason Silva and tune in
to brain games on National Geographic
which is airing in the US as well as the
UK and in September in a hundred
countries so watch brain games on Nat
Geo thanks a lot guys Jason Silva shots
of awe signing off see you soon